birthday balloons falling limply to the
ground
satellites medical scanners and TVs
fading to Black and twinkling stars in
the night sky disappearing one by one
all in just five seconds without helium
what would the loss of helium do to your
body
how would the rest of the universe react
to this molecular on off switch
and could this bring about the end of
our solar system
this is what if and here's what would
happen if all helium disappeared for
five seconds
hey helium isn't just your party balloon
filler upper it's the second most
abundant element in the universe and the
second lightest too behind only hydrogen
helium can be found on both planets and
moons but most of all stars
after all it was discovered in 1868 by
astronomers who observed a yellow light
in the sun's Corona during a solar
eclipse
that's how it got its name from the
Greek god Helios
and even though this gas isn't something
you need for your biological functions
it's an important part of your everyday
life I really shouldn't be doing this
it's used in the lasers of barcode
readers medical Machinery like MRI
scanners and scientific research
equipment like cern's Large Hadron
Collider and it also helps prevent stars
from exploding
so would five seconds without helium
lead to the biggest Interstellar
fireworks show of all time
well the moment that helium disappears
from the universe you'd barely notice
anything
our atmosphere contains almost no helium
so you'd keep on breathing without any
issues
but hopefully you weren't in the middle
of an MRI scan when all of this goes
down
these use a ton of energy and have super
conducting magnets that need to be kept
cold very cold
without the minus 269 degrees Celsius
chill of liquid helium running through
the wires the magnets would overheat if
you were in the machine at this moment
you could get some serious Burns
scientists working with cern's Large
Hadron Collider would immediately run
into a similar issue except they'd
suddenly lose
120 tons of liquid helium
and now they'd have increasingly hot
magnets steering The Machine's particle
beams
and of course the worst thing that would
happen is the rapid deflation of every
birthday balloon on the planet
that would make for a lot of very sad
kids
okay maybe this wouldn't be the worst
because none of these problems would
compare to what would start happening
around the rest of the universe once all
the helium disappeared
in the core of our sun helium is
produced by the nuclear fusion of
hydrogen atoms and not just a little bit
either
the sun produces 700 million tons of
helium every second
this nuclear fusion process exerts an
enormous amount of outward pressure
and without being contained somehow this
would explode just like a hydrogen bomb
good thing there's inward pressure
formed by the sun's massive
gravitational pull this attraction of
the gas mantles surrounding the core
provides enough of a balance to keep
things from blowing up
but if all the helium vanished a large
amount of the Sun's mass would be gone
and with that it would have less
gravitational pull this would upset that
precious balance
so now our sun would be on the verge of
exploding and you could count on that
being very bad news for you and everyone
else back on Earth
now with any luck this wouldn't happen
the five seconds would be up and our sun
would maintain its pressure as all of
its helium is once again restored to its
rightful place
yeah I'm sure MRIs and the Large Hadron
Collider could be out of service for a
while but at least you could spend the
rest of your life counting your lucky
stars
although make sure you keep an eye open
for which stars those are
looking up you could see a permanently
darker night sky
some Stars didn't fare as well as our
own
and as their light travels you could see
evidence of their explosions for many
years to come
now you'd also be fortunate that it was
helium that disappeared from the
universe for five seconds
at least it wasn't something a bit more
ascent
Ascent Like Oxygen
but that's a story
for another
what if